something very exciting here at
congratulations podcast we have new
limited edition merch drop we have a
limited edition of new colorways
and uh uh that are life
rips hoodies shorts and also hats we
have [ __ ] trucker hats
cause guess what baby back in style dude
wearing backwards or forwards and being
the coolest [ __ ] in the world
life rips rep that life rip [ __ ] cause
life rips because and you know it does
dude it life rips if you make it rip and
now you can support these new [ __ ]
this this uh
this lifestyle how life rips with the uh
with the new colorways that are a
limited edition
it's kind of um it's very cool it's got
80s vibes
and uh and we like it over here
congratulations i can't wait till mine
comes in
and uh also um this
is something it is limited edition uh
all you youtube people
my patreon subscribers got first dibs i
don't know if it's sold out yet uh i'm
not sure i have to check
but the patreon subscribers got first
dibs on it so
thanks for listening and go to
crystallia.com crystal.com to go get
that new
colorway limited edition life rips merch
what's up baby this is the podcast
[Music]
congratulations
all right man it's on
and it's on because i said so that's
eric eric uh wright what's his name ez
that's him and the sound and the song
because i said so
so [ __ ] hard to be in a relationship
with him probably anyway
um what's up dude we're just chilling
here
having a good time and i tried to book a
uh
a car ride for um
my uh my fiance's dad
to get here and the guy asked me uh what
my last name was
and i s for the account and i said dalia
and he's can you spell that and i said
d-e-l-i-a and he said
can you spell that again please i said
dalia d-e-l-i-a and he said oh sodelia
and i said sure because why would you
argue with somebody that you never met
and don't even know what they look like
isn't it right dude i say sure if that's
how you want to do it
then sure okay that's fine
i love starting this pot i love starting
this podcast pissed
[ __ ] yeah dude
[Music]
previously on congratulations
um you know dude we have a good time
and we keeps it real and
it's all good and those are the three
most important rules of life we have a
good time we keeps it real
and it's all good so um
why don't we just lead with that even
though
um we do it it is what it is and it is
what it is that's another thing that you
got to remember a bunch of things it is
what it is
uh it's all good and you
[Music]
whatever it's fine dude today i was i
was
i was done working out i got my [ __ ]
my thighs all nice
they were just i was doing squats i was
doing uh
rearfoot elevated split squats squats
and you're probably like wow that's a
tough workout that's amazing you did all
that i'm not done yet
i also did uh freaking chin-ups
and you're probably like whoa that's
crazy that that's wild
that's crazy when are you gonna work out
next i'm like well i'm not done yet yeah
juan done yet
and um and uh
i did uh i also [ __ ]
what else did i do oh um
the rose back rows you're probably like
wow i'm like oh i ain't done yet
and then i did uh also other leg things
that i can't remember which is great
[ __ ] can't even oh yeah step throughs
the [ __ ] lunge step throughs and
that's
and i also did core and he did core and
he did [ __ ] core
so i did lots of stuff from my chest on
down
i'm just
and then from my and my back is all nice
it's like a
you know it's like a turtle so um
but i you know and also it's like a
turtle because i move very slow
uh after i work out but i was done
working out
almost vomited right there but i was
done working out and then
kristen was like i have a headache can
you get me ibuprofen
and i was like guess i'm the butler but
sure
you know i guess i'm the butler but sure
but i said yeah sure and it's always
under the sink in the bathroom and she
said
you know what there may not be any more
under the sink in the bathroom but there
but you may have to use the uh ibuprofen
on the uh side table of the bedroom on
your side and i go like this
okay and i'm already like it better be
in there
and it better be easy to find because
there's a bunch of [ __ ] in there because
side tables on bed and the sides of beds
always have like the most random [ __ ] in
it you know
you'll have like uh
like your nighttime medicine and like
a book and also like a half-eaten yogurt
you know and um and a dead cat and so
i went to look in there and there were
nail clippers there were books
and there were a lot of things that
would be in there and the things that i
did not see
were ibuprofen but i did see tic tacs so
i thought you know what it's not easy to
find
she asked me to do it guess i'm the
butler now but guess what kind of butler
i am
i'm butler with jokes right i'm the
butler who's gonna be the butler that's
also got a little bit he's got like a
slight sense of humor
and uh i'm the prank butler so i i took
the tic tacs
and i couldn't [ __ ] wait to give them
to her dude and tell her it was
ibuprofen
and i couldn't wait and i even filled up
water for i made it extra nice because
your boy was a jokester he's a bother
but he's a jokester
so i brought the uh tic tacs over to her
and she was on the couch and i was
standing up and i handed them to her
and i couldn't wait you know and i go
here's the water and i handed it to her
and she goes
she looks at the tic-tacs dude it
couldn't have been funnier she looked at
the tic tacs
and then she stayed looking at it for a
while and i'm like my tummy's moving i'm
like trying not to laugh and then she
just looks up at me and she goes like
this
and nothing could be funnier and i
started [ __ ] howling
and she says why did you give me tic
tacs
and that was it dude the day was over
there are other things that happened
beyond that in the day but that
was when the day ended because you can't
get better than that dude
and we have fun dude we're together and
we have fun and we do silly things
that's the kind of silly relationship
that we're in
um and then and then i said well it
wasn't she what the [ __ ]
were you just gonna let me take take tic
tacs
and i was like well yeah and then i was
probably gonna tell you later you know
imagine people
just swallowing tic tacs and not chewing
them dude
like just how much would a f a foreigner
do that thinking that it's like oh you
just swallowed these and
and they remember breath ashore do you
guys remember breath ashore
i remember breath ashore i thought that
was the [ __ ] man you would just put
breath ashore in your mouth
and then drink it and then it went out
of business or something it's not around
anymore but you'd put it in your mouth
and then you'd drink the water and then
it would go in your mouth and it would
like
sprout a [ __ ] nice smelling forest in
your belly and whenever you burped it
would smell like parsley
and it was just awesome you'd be at a
party just [ __ ] burping from the taco
bell you ate in high school and people
be like what the [ __ ] is
did somebody grow moss dude it was the
[ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] does it smell like a
goddamn rain forest in here for and
you're like sorry i had taco bell
breath is sure and then it just and then
i was like you know what
i don't like chewing gum so i'm just
gonna get so many breath of shores
and then i went to cvs i didn't have
breath of shores then i went to rite aid
they didn't have breath of shorts i went
to save on drugs they didn't have breath
of shores
and then that was when i realized that
there was no more [ __ ] breath to
shores
if there's breath to the two doors now
i'm taking them dude can't wait to smell
like parsley
um just [ __ ] party smelling like
parsley
that's when you knew the real [ __ ] the
the [ __ ] sober guy at the party just
burping burping up parsley just burping
up liquid parsley
so gross anyway uh she didn't take the
tic tacs
and then i was like well i was just
gonna see oh i also secretly kind of
wanted to see this is shitty but i
secretly wanted to see
um if she thought her headache was gonna
be better you know
because that's something about her that
she'll be like
you know
i don't even know actually what i'm
trying to say here i also actually don't
know if maybe if i don't even talk about
this am i gonna am i in [ __ ] hot
water right now am i gonna get in
trouble after this
is she gonna be like you know what you
said in the podcast wasn't cool um
but anyway whatever i picked her up from
that party and she was super
super high and uh and drunk and all that
so
um what tuna story are you talking about
wonder what oh this is exactly the point
dude
[Laughter]
dude i uh i have such a weird [ __ ]
thing about people i always think
they're lying and [ __ ]
and uh she she all of a sudden was just
like you know what sushi makes me have a
stomachache
and and i was like great great great
great a new thing that you're just gonna
fire out there that you just say with no
basis because you had
sushi probably twice and now you want to
be the person who just can't
says things like i can't eat sushi
because it gives me tummy eggs yeah dude
[ __ ] yeah we got another one we got
another thing to think of
whoa and uh
and so i'm like all right cool and then
of course
doing the pandemic i would be like man
can we get sugar fresh
sugar fish and she's just like make
memory about my tummy and i was like
yeah
yeah okay well i'm gonna get sugar fish
and she'd be like well then i have to
get a separate postmates and i'm like so
and she's like yeah but i just then it
shows up at different times and i'm like
so
if you keep saying so to somebody they
realize they're wrong even if they're
right
did you know that that's something that
you should know
it's windy out so hair all in your face
yeah well no i'm just saying so what
yeah no but it
i guess the you know the wind is [ __ ]
it's crazy today so
i don't know it's not windy that's how
that conversation would go
and so um so
so so she um
i'm like all right [ __ ] i gotta
i gotta not get [ __ ] sugarfish now i
forgot to feel bad when i'm eating it
dude
that nice buttery salmon i'm taking
pieces of buttery salmon and i'm just
[ __ ]
inserting them into my mouth and having
them dance around my [ __ ] tongue
and the flavors the flavor is
spectacular mexican
the flavor is spectacular and uh the
flavor is [ __ ] spectacular dude you
throw that [ __ ]
that butter soft [ __ ] salmon from
sugarfish
into your mouth and it just dances
around it's having a party it's going
from [ __ ]
opposite member of the opposite sex to
member of the opposite sex just trying
to [ __ ] get laid right in your mouth
dude
that's what that nice buttery salmon
from uh
sugarfish is trying to do in your mouth
before you [ __ ] swallow it whole
right
and uh so we got so now i can't get it
and i'm like well let's just you know
and so then
a lot of times i wasn't getting it and
then sometimes i would still get it and
she would order from something else and
they would come
sometimes at the same time two ubereats
guys would show up and just they'd
be like they show up at the same time
they'd be like hey well i guess we're
friends now for the rest of our lives
and so um are you uber or are you
posting postmates oh i'm uber oh hey
how's it going
just falling in love oh that's funny wow
god it's crazy huh
so where are you where are you are
they're both getting their kias and just
[ __ ] room out and so
so um
[Music]
i i you know we had we had couples
therapy
once and and she was like
why is it so you know
i think we're talking about how i'm
selfish and i was like how come i can't
just get sugar fish when i want to get
sugar fish and [ __ ]
and then it came out that i was like i
think that i think that she's not really
being
serious about this the stomach this
dummy stuff i think
she's actually like lying you know what
i mean and the therapist said you think
she's lying about having a stomach ache
and that was when i realized
i was an insane person so there we go do
it we
we live and we learn we live and we
learn now is it my mom's fault because
when i was a kid she would say stuff
like that i don't
know i'm not saying yes and i'm not
saying no
i hope she doesn't see this podcast but
um
yeah dude i don't know but uh
you know who knows what it's for but
then i was like [ __ ] why the [ __ ] would
she lie about that
because i get my i get in my in my head
that people
want to be things
so badly like they latch onto
things that they want because they
it's like the thing i made fun of on
tick tock that people are [ __ ]
just being so mad at me about about the
the
the stand up i did with the with the
working out how you're not inspiring
anybody
when they're and someone commented like
working out is not
a personality and it's like that's how i
feel like people are with stuff
and it goes right down to
um hey sushi gives me a stomachache
i'm like you're just trying to [ __ ]
have a personality
not on my watch
what a [ __ ] lightning rod
of a piece of [ __ ] i am and uh
like one time when i was this is this is
i think this is when it started dude if
i had to [ __ ] think about a time when
it
started when i started to think that
people were
were blowing [ __ ] out of proportion
because everybody's a conspiracy
theorist in their own head
even if you don't talk about it if you
eat sushi and you get a tummy ache
you're like that's from the sushi i
can't eat that sushi anymore when this
is not necessarily true
right but i am not saying that she was
lying because she obviously was getting
a
a [ __ ] sushi for getting
a stomachache right every time so but
what i am saying is i remember
the inception of the moment that i
started thinking everybody was lying and
it was
columbine and i will explain okay before
you [ __ ] cancel me again for bringing
this up
it was columbine uh columbine happened
it was 1990 whatever it was
and my and we were learning about it on
the kitchen tv
we had a kitchen tv when i was in high
school and it was one of those tvs that
was this big
and the image was this big right so it
looked like a [ __ ] toaster that you
couldn't even put a full piece of bread
in
and they will go like live
coming from live coming from coming from
colorado
was that's where it was right columbine
is in colorado yeah
live coming from colorado there's
children you shoot shooting
inside and my mom was holding a notebook
because she was doing something with a
notebook and i and we both saw the tv
and we both looked at the
the stuff the news and it was bad right
really bad
and my mom dropped the notebook
in shock and i don't think the moment
like here i am she drops the notebook
i'm like what who is she [ __ ] kaiser
jose at the end of the movie just
dropping the [ __ ] coffee cup
uh chaz pometeri dropping the coffee cup
just like
like that doesn't happen in real life
it's cinematic and so she drops her
notebook
and i think the mo i don't think that
would have been the inception
except for the fact that the notebook
hit my foot and i wasn't wearing shoes
and it didn't hurt a little bit
it hurt so much because like the end of
the notebook
bonked on my foot and i go god i go
[ __ ] mom you dropped the [ __ ]
notebook right
and she was like oh shut the [ __ ] up and
she walks over to the tv
and i'm just like dude she didn't need
to drop the notebook she did that for
her
this is how [ __ ] up i already was a 16
16 year old she did that for her
she did that because she thinks life's a
movie
like i made this is what i was thinking
and i always thought people thought that
they were the leads in their own movies
and [ __ ] and that's why i made that
stand up and man on fire about how like
everybody thinks they're denzel
and then i realized who gives this [ __ ]
who cares about that
who really honestly gives a [ __ ] about
that that much if somebody thinks
they're in a [ __ ] movie and they want
to be denzel washington walking into
making a deposit because of their
[ __ ]
uh paycheck from tender greens who gives
a [ __ ]
it was adding so much [ __ ] stress to
my life and shittiness
and why the [ __ ] would i not trust
somebody because they have a stomach
ache from [ __ ] sushi
so now we're better people [ __ ]
absolutely
yes
[ __ ] renner take me out
still why don't my mom drop the no one
you know what i mean but he's still got
a little bit of
he still got a little bit of it in
himself because it kind of makes him him
yeah dude keep the good parts dispose of
the bad parts
that goes from when you're cooking
chicken to working on yourself
oh man so i don't even really know i
didn't mean to talk about this but
that's but the tic tacs thing was funny
um i should have named my kid blaze
blaze dalia it's blaze and the monster
machine
it's blaze and the monster machine but a
lot of
blazing the monster machines
my kid watches that and kristen always
knows all the words immediately to all
the theme songs like how do you do that
she's like i just listen and that's when
i feel like a piece of [ __ ]
it's plays in the monster machines it's
blaze
and the [ __ ] monster machines every
day we blaze in the monster machines
every day we blaze talking about weed um
it's coke and the monster machines it's
cocaine
and the monster machines i [ __ ] don't
like when they put those secret
[ __ ] in the children's shows like
remember when the little mermaid [ __ ]
guy came out of the water need a boner
didn't like it
keep keep that [ __ ] [ __ ] disney dude
it's plays and the monster machine leans
we take liberties dude whenever anyone
sings and they do a few extra notes they
do
i say oh taking liberties and one time i
left
the house and i had to come back in to
get my keys and kristen was singing a
song and a holy [ __ ] [ __ ] she
was taking
so many liberties dude and i said taking
liberties and she said oh i thought you
left already
dude and we have fun in our relationship
man
i said dude [ __ ] taking a little
birdie dude she was doing [ __ ] like
you know what she was doing she was
doing it oh dude we gotta find this
video
pull up that video of the of the girl
singing
be humble you know what i'm talking
about do you know what i'm talking about
oh my god if we can find this we might
have to cut and find this but this is
unbelievable hold on
singing be humble this is how this is
what the kind of [ __ ] she was doing dude
let me see if i can find this
here it is we got it whoa johnny [ __ ]
fast finds
johnny fast finds at it again johnny
quick fingers at it again
dude and it's the top thing that came up
because he [ __ ] absolutely
went from johnny quick fingers
transformed into johnny fast finds
and [ __ ] pull he knows what to type
in google johnny knows what to type it
in
unbelievable dude whoa we found it [ __ ]
it
yeah dude expose the bicep because he
deserves it
[ __ ] yeah he deserves to show off a
little bit because he's johnny
finds it quick [ __ ] yeah dude
how could you listen to npr when there's
this
[Music]
this is the kind of this is the most so
taken liberty ass
song singing that i could ever find
and we are going to play it and if
youtube demonetizes us for this
i don't care i will make zero money on
this episode because use [ __ ]
need to see this [ __ ]
but guess what i could easily cut this
part out if they do demonetize it you'll
never hear me say that so here we go
here's what it is dude
screaming baby
[Music]
it's so bad it doesn't matter if it's
good do you know what i'm talking about
she's in her [ __ ] car
pulled over and playing it on her
[ __ ] hooked in without the bluetooth
it's hooked in you know
that's how you really know you're [ __ ]
up in life she [ __ ] hooked it in
my left stroke just went viral
at taking so many liberties
pop the trunk what's in there oh
that was hiding in the trunk for three
miles
my left stroke just went viral
unbelievable dude to have that many
[ __ ] taking the liberties
my left stroke just went viral
let's listen to a little bit more that's
unreal dude she thought she killed it
she kind of did kill it
but it doesn't matter oh i forgot that i
forgot that i forgot the banger part
[Music]
the window just in the background
i was screaming
[Music]
opera dude
why she doing the volume control it's
like the [ __ ] austin power [ __ ]
can you hear the sound of my voice or
whatever it is such a dork that i did
that
um let's go to the comments
let's go to the somebody said when you
sing in 23 different fonts
oh this guy also was johnny [ __ ]
finds it quick because he said i just
looked up that girl singing humble
i can't believe that it's [ __ ] well
it's three years old okay
unbelievable rory lee shout out to rory
lee singing humble
well i've stroked just one more
it's like if the [ __ ] cranberry is
saying kendrick lamar
or that one that goes who's that what's
that song that goes
oh that is cranberries oh we [ __ ]
didn't know he's got a tumor
he's working on a tumor folks
[ __ ] yeah dude the song that krista was
singing was
absolutely the best one she could be
singing she was singing take me out to
the ball game i remember now and that's
unbelievable
to take liberties in a [ __ ] song you
sing and the seventh inning stretch
oh she was like take me out to the ball
game take me out to the crowd
buy me some peanuts and cracker jacks
and when i walked in she was doing that
i don't care if i ever get mad she did
the run she did like a long run if i oh
i'll get back dude and i went taking a
liberties dude
carter carter
caught her
[ __ ] caught her dude you know what i
mean
caught her doing that she caught me
cheating
it's even we're even
i caught her [ __ ] singing take me out
to the ballgame and taking liberties
while doing so
and she caught me she she caught me
cheating great
fair's fair i caught her singing
take me out to the ball game in a
[ __ ] operatic manner and she caught
me cheating
guess where even even steven my left
strong just
went viral so bad
i killed it um so anyway dude
that was the most to take in liberty ass
song
uh and that's that
you know what i'm done with my
neighborhood that's what i'm done with
i'm done with my neighborhood i go out
sometimes i work out outside sometimes i
take a little bit of a walk i go with
calvin or whatever the [ __ ] we go as a
family we
walk down the street there's always like
a [ __ ] one lady that's just listening
to music as she's walking
she doesn't have headphones in she uses
the [ __ ] phone
and and it's just like blaring out which
is fine
but like smile when you see somebody you
smile
she doesn't give a [ __ ] dude these
people don't care there's one good
there's a cool dude he's a famous dude
and he lives
down the way and uh whenever i see him
he just had a kid whenever i see him
we're like this you know what i mean
i do it cool he's much cooler than me
and i just do it i do it like i try to
do it like i know i'm not that cool but
i i'm gonna do like what's up and he'll
be like what's up and i'm just like and
then i feel really good
um so there's that guy but there's just
like
you know other dude it's like i i feel
like i live like it's like
every time i go out it's like the
beginning of a [ __ ] horror movie is
what it's like i'll
i'll walk out and then somebody will
drive by and they'll just drive by and
they'll do that [ __ ] drive-by where
they're just driving by and they're just
like
and you're just like is that a ghost do
you know what i mean and it's just some
lady that looks
like rich as [ __ ] and she just lives
nine houses down and you never
and their lights are never on and you're
just like what's going on dude
people walk by just watch you you'll
walk by and they'll just stop walking
and just stare at you just
say hi if i smile you smile i smile i'm
whole
i'm great i spilled water [ __ ] yes
it's wet it's wet as [ __ ] it's wet
everywhere
yes dude we did it and we keep moving
and we keep
moving and we keep moving in the
neighborhood discussion
was it even worth it i don't know will i
keep this and while i cut it out who
knows but we did it and we moved through
it
and with hard work and dedication you
can [ __ ] do it and you can even do it
while you're wet and i'm soaked
dude
[ __ ] soaked if it was the old me i'd
take my [ __ ] shirt off and do the
rest of the podcast but he keeps it nice
we keeps it nice now
we watched this [ __ ] 2020 dude we're
on the 2020 binge dude wow i could wring
it out
we're on a 20 20 binge and we [ __ ]
watched this thing
paulo oh [ __ ] what let me look it up
because i can't remember his last name
it was like mancini or some [ __ ] paulo
uh 2020 i could get i got it 20
20 paulo
mclarini i mean made up
paolo maclarini this dude we watched
this 2020 on it
and 2020 kills it you know what i mean
it was a regular day in 2008 and you're
like it was wasn't it
and you're just settling in you got your
meal or your popcorn
rebecca somebody met paulo
uh went in for surgery it was a normal
day
blah blah and you're like it was normal
wasn't it she was just getting surgery
but but it's not but it wasn't normal
for long and you're like you're right it
was i could tell
you know i could tell guy i could tell
voiceover guy
this woman [ __ ] met i can't believe
you should watch it i guess but you know
or i'll just tell you it
but this guy paolo macchiarini
was in uh was a guy who
was a surgeon and he was like a
world-class surgeon and he made
a trachea for people
who whose trachea was [ __ ] up
i'm very medical so that's why i'm
talking about it like this
but if you had a broken ass trachea he
made
tracheas and would take your broken ass
trachea out
and just slide in a new one and then you
just pop up and be like
let's let's play baseball or some or you
know let me eat up [ __ ] something you
know what i mean
let me breathe regular and eat full
meals so this guy
was this rock star surgeon and he would
just replace your trachea dude just like
it was nothing like it was like wha
like it was literally like watching
[ __ ] uh dennis the menace just that's
how he did it he was just like oh yeah
some people watch dennis the medicine
some people replace dracus but he was a
rock star and he looked cool
they described him on 2020 like how he
was like a little bit like george
clooney even though he wasn't
sometimes they get a little bit
confident with their [ __ ]
he was just like george clooney and if
you look at him and he's just like
but he was handsome and he was the [ __ ]
he had a lot of money
and um they were doing a documentary on
him
i think the lady worked for abc or
whatever and they were doing the the
rock star life of this
paolo mac maclaren machiarini
and uh and she [ __ ] fell in love with
him because he's such a [ __ ]
dope dude he's like i replaced trey it's
like i mean like for real man
if you met a guy at a party and you were
like hey what's up and he's like hey
what's up what do you do she's like i
just you know i'm
i [ __ ] anything i bag groceries to oh
i'm a [ __ ]
news correspondent or oh i'm i'm
i'm a doctor even if she's like i'm a
doctor and then this guy's like
that's cute what do you do i replace
tracheas
immediately it's just oh i
i had no i
okay would you like a drink and then you
buy him the drink you understand
and so she fell in love with him and she
was doing the story on him and that's a
no-no
if you don't know anything about the
journalist world which i do it's a no-no
you don't fall in love with the subject
of your [ __ ] thing
right so
but she did because the guy was so he
was just that
dope wasn't he and so um
she said [ __ ] it i quit i want
they they fell in love he asked her to
marry him and he
said that there was going to be a
wedding and he's like listen i gotta
tell you something i have a really high
profile
uh clientele they pay extra money and
there's like this whole
it's like this whole society and i i i
work on them
and these people include barack obama
the pope uh
bro he said these people include barack
obama the pope
uh the clintons and also russell crowe
that's
what he's that was the fourth one which
already
he's like the politicians and russell
crowe and i'm like
hell yeah dude and i'm thinking does
russell crowe have one of these tracheas
in him
so he said okay i got a meeting with the
pope and she was like wow
amazing and he comes back after the
meeting and he says i got to tell you
something
the pope's going to marry us and she
goes
what now here i am now i know i'm
watching the 2020. and obviously they're
showing this because this [ __ ]
is an insane person
and either either he's lying
or at the end he kills a bunch of people
that's the only thing what happens in
the 2020s is either he kills a bunch of
people
or he up he lied the whole time and it
wasn't who you thought he was
and sometimes it's both okay
so she's like i'm sorry the pope is
gonna marry us does he even do that and
he's like no
but he's gonna do it for us she's like
what
she tells the friends and the friends
are like what
well i guess it makes sense if he
replaces tracheous and he's a rock star
they [ __ ] know
and he works with the obamas and [ __ ]
so he says yeah our wedding is in spain
great or um our wedding is in spain
and it's in whatever may if you're
getting ready everyone buys the tickets
to [ __ ] spain
they all spend so many 300 people buy
non-refundable tickets to spain
and he uh they buy dresses and [ __ ]
the bride's groom shits and the
bridesmaids and all this [ __ ]
and two weeks to the wedding they're
gonna do it in the church
two weeks into the wedding two weeks to
the wedding one of the friends say
to this news reporter who fell over them
hey you know how like you said the pope
is gonna marry you
i mean dude this this woman had like gay
friends and he was like i can't believe
we're going to get to go to the wedding
and the pope is going to give us
communion he said hey the guy said hey
you're going to give all your gay
friends communion back then the
the pope you know catholicism didn't
want anything to do with gays
so the the gay guys were like crying
like i can't believe it you know
two weeks before the wedding the friend
calls the [ __ ] news reporter lady
and he's like hey did you say they were
gonna get married the public got married
yeah
the pope is scheduled to be in south
america in two weeks
and i'm like yeah okay because he's
lying
you know and she's like what so she
calls him he says no they
they [ __ ] it up somebody's trying to
go higher than the pope
and uh and and and and and they're using
this is strong i'm like who the [ __ ] is
higher than the pope
who is it god is jesus just like hey you
got to be
sorry i know you got to marry this
[ __ ] this trachea replacer guy but we
got to [ __ ] move you down to south
america we got to be at south america
for some [ __ ] function
so she's like she's like well that's
weird i'm going to call the hotel just a
kid cause a hotel
no record of the hotel of the marriage
of the [ __ ]
wedding parties close the restaurant for
the rehearsal dinner and the thing
no record no record of anything so she's
like what the [ __ ] so she decides [ __ ]
it i'm a reporter
i'm gonna play cool i'm gonna be with
the dude i'm not gonna show my cards but
i'm gonna find out as much as i can
hey what the [ __ ] is going on just run
dude
he's a liar just run and it turned out
that this guy was falsifying credentials
he somehow weasels his way
in through school matrix the trach is
turned out to be just
[ __ ] for real water bottles
that he would [ __ ] thin down and put
into your throat and
your skin would grow over it so 15
people [ __ ]
died because this guy said he could
replace her tricia
and it didn't work dude so she showed up
to his [ __ ] house
with the non-refundable ticket at the
end of the [ __ ] uh instead of going
to the wedding
she showed up to his house and he had
another [ __ ]
family of course because that's how this
ends
but my question and my main question is
hey guy don't you care
don't you have stress about all of this
cheating was hard enough cheating
is so stressful but you're pretending
that you're saving people's lives
replacing their tracheas
and have not one but two
families already the barcelona [ __ ]
house
he had a family and that wasn't his main
even his main family dude
hey guy what were you going to do
when everyone showed up for the wedding
if nobody found out the pope is going to
be in south america
what the [ __ ] was your plan
this is the most amazing thing ever and
this is true
dude this isn't a movie that stars chris
evans probably
you know what i mean that that's the
thing he would take after he [ __ ]
shot captain america
he's like you know what i'm tired of
these [ __ ] crazy roles let me play
paulo macharini the trachea replacement
guy
still with his [ __ ] no matter what
role chris evans ever does i still want
him to have his captain america [ __ ]
shield on his back
that would be [ __ ] hilarious dude
but dude that's the kind of [ __ ]
sociopath if you're going
to be a sociopath that's the kind
you have to be all out dude
oh oh i don't oh i replaced tracheas
you do yeah you know the science oh yeah
i know it all
and you don't and the people are gonna
die
no they're not 15 die uh
it had to do with something else
honestly they didn't keep up with their
medical plan afterwards
really wait you have one extra family no
i have two
i have two great my dogs are barking so
much it's unbelievable hopefully we
can't hear a minute but if you can
that's just the way it goes man
i [ __ ] cannot believe this guy paolo
macchiarini
wow why were there so many dogs barking
dude
for so long is it okay you think oh wow
he says probably
so he definitely knows he's not
definitely knows it's not
if you're barking dude i hate when my
[ __ ] dogs bark man
when my dogs bark how about this how do
you feel when your dogs bark
do you get angry i want to know and i
also want to know if you had four dogs
and they were all barking
how do you feel dude i get so blood
curdling man i get brm i get [ __ ]
blood red mad that's what i get
it's chenzo that [ __ ] just
i'll walk in ra and i'm like hey it's me
and just
guess what happened yesterday a [ __ ]
snake bit him okay a snake [ __ ]
bitter
dude this dog that how about that how
about that for comeuppance
the animal kingdom was like oh you're
gonna [ __ ] behead
uh uh uh a [ __ ] pigeon
and eat two dead lizards well
you we've gotta well hey nature kingdom
was just like we got another thing
coming
the dude [ __ ] the net the nature
kingdom the [ __ ] animal kingdom wrong
kingdom [ __ ] face
um yeah dude so he got bit by a snake
i was watching the [ __ ] 2020 and i
reached back chen is always on the top
of the pillow just denting it
and i reach back and i'm just petting
him i'm being like a nice guy even
though
we're at our odds because he's always
[ __ ] barking at me
and i [ __ ] reach back and i'm petting
him and all of a sudden he goes
i'm just like well he's a crazy dog so
who knows he probably has trauma
somebody who was a [ __ ] tall drink of
water in six foot two and had shoulders
that they shot the lord of the rings on
probably pet him once and then beat the
[ __ ] out of him and now i'm
you know i when i do it he's just like
it's
it flashes back to that and he's just
like
and i'm like what the [ __ ] what a weird
okay maybe he pulled his back or has a
ruptured disc or something and i [ __ ]
chill for the bed i reached back i put
him again
again he makes the same noise so i'm
like what the [ __ ] and then later on
we're in bed and chances are chilling
and we're like why is chance not you
know what was weird
why the [ __ ] is chen's not running
around spazzing out when we took the
pizza out i ate pizza
sorry it wasn't in my diet
but uh why was he not running around
because this [ __ ] dude when we
pull out food
this [ __ ] runs around pisses
everywhere and just
barks barks we get chinese food he'll
take a [ __ ] on the table for real
dude he'll piss on the plates my dog
will piss on the plates
that's no joke if we walk out of the
room to take
to go to the bathroom he'll be like this
oh you go there well i go here and piss
on the plates dude he pisses on the dog
food and he pisses on the people food
and i'm not making that up for jokes he
does it
and we're like he was weird we took the
pizza out and he was it was like he was
on a sedative
that's [ __ ] weird and we looked at
him closely and he had a [ __ ]
mark on his back and it was like a
puncture wound it was like jesus chris
what happened
honestly who knows with this
[ __ ] this guy could have been
out trying to [ __ ] buy a ham sandwich
and got
shot in a deli he's a crazy
[ __ ] dog like maybe he tried to get
under the gate and just at all
costs while the [ __ ] bottom of the
gate was just but he was like [ __ ] i
could do it and then realize okay
[ __ ] i can
and then just came back with something
that looked like a hatchet wound
and then we're like wow that's weird
okay well whatever hopefully he'll be
okay
and kristen's like great we got to call
the [ __ ] ambulance and i'm like what
ambulance she's like there's one for
animals and i'm like
not doing that let's just throw them off
the roof
and she's like well we have you know
she's like we've had a rough year what
are we gonna [ __ ] what's gonna cost
40k you know what i mean
and she's like um
and she's like well we should do
something maybe we should take it and
i'm like i'm so tired we gotta get up at
[ __ ] 8 30 you know i'm like let's
just it
it's probably gonna be okay and then we
look at the [ __ ]
around more and an inch away there's
another puncture wound
great a snake bit him
[Music]
just chenzo barking barking barking
eating lizards
biting heads off of [ __ ] birds well
that snake [ __ ] came up and he
was just like
i heard what you did in arizona and then
[ __ ]
oh i heard what you did in arizona
he did a [ __ ] and i hope it i hope it
happened honestly because he's cool now
and then kristen was like well what is
he gonna die what if it was a [ __ ]
viper i'm just like what poisonous it
was around it could have been a
rattlesnake he'd be dead already you
know
he weighs [ __ ] i mean he's chonk he's
[ __ ] chunk dude
he is [ __ ] chunk because he now lives
in [ __ ] goddamn beverly hills and he
used to live in panorama city
and he just [ __ ] hops up on the table
and eats whatever the [ __ ] is there
we'll look away and it will look back
it's like you know the thing when batman
did when
in all the batman movies we were like
okay batman thanks
one more batman and he's gone that's
chen's only stealing sweet potato fries
you're just like what's that where the
[ __ ] my whole goddamn three-course
meal
and chenza is in the corner just like
so good i'm glad he got attacked by a
[ __ ] snake he's fine
and it wasn't poisonous because he had
already been dead but then we went to
bed we woke up
and the puncture wounds were you know
doing much better we looked it up on
google we're like how long does it take
a dog to die when he gets
[ __ ] attacked by a a rattlesnake and
they were like half hour
and i was like well i pet him like 40
minutes ago this [ __ ] would be
in v fib
and then it was kristen well what if it
wasn't a snake you know it could be a
a hawk that's what she said oh yeah it
could also maybe it was a zebra who
knows
covet
um i don't know man my dogs are insane
they bark too much and i hate it
but i love them i love them because they
[ __ ] i didn't realize i didn't you
don't realize you love your dogs until
they run away every single one of my
dogs is run away and they all came back
that's how good they have it i left the
gate open by mistake they ran away
and they [ __ ] came back they got
outside and they were like wow this
really sucks
i got it good we got pillows and [ __ ]
and always food let's go back
they both came back together by the way
they both left and then came back
together
the next morning the next [ __ ]
morning i hear
at my door i open it up and they're just
like hey what's up we're on vacation
that real world sucks out there did you
know that yeah i have an idea
um what's up you want to do the [ __ ]
2020 thing you want to watch 2020 and
we'll just
go nuts when you open pizza is that what
you want um
but yeah so
i had to convince myself when when they
were when they were gone
that was when i really realized holy
[ __ ] i [ __ ] loved them and i started
i was like crying and [ __ ] and i was
like i don't know if i'm ever gonna get
them back
and i had to convince myself um
[ __ ] it they left because they wanted to
it was their own choice you know i know
that they're dumb [ __ ] animals and
[ __ ] and they don't know wolves
are out there but they left because they
wanted to they did what they wanted
if they get eaten by a coyote they die
doing what they love it's like the end
of point break
keanu reeves is like all right see you
later patrick swayze
this is just like one more ride
[ __ ] and it goes out there and
you never see him again
my dogs were patrick swayze and i was
keanu reeves
and it was that dramatic and it was that
good of a movie too
if you had filmed it
sorry little kids i'mma kill a clown
today
what else do i have here to talk about
oh this is a video
he hurt himself so bad dude
[Laughter]
video from this on my discord this is
from my patreon sign up for my patreon
if you want to send me segment ideas and
videos
disgusting bird wow change it
video from disgusting bird disc disc
golfer throws 530 foot
hole in one wow
people will just be good at anything huh
you know five
a there's no baseball field that's 530
feet
dude 530 feet is
so far if you walk to there you'd get
tired
and this guy is perfecting the
disc golfer throw also two
sports hybrided in one is so [ __ ]
stupid already
and this guy's just murdering the
[ __ ] disc golf [ __ ]
the wind up he takes javelin players
in the olympics would be like i gotta
take notes from that guy
and his course is wearing shorts here we
go
let's watch it
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] it's too
[ __ ] hard the centripetal force of it
of his turnaround
is too hard that his knee is just like
i'll meet the ground
immediately oh hello ground
ow goes oh no oh some guy goes
oh no some guy who was just some [ __ ]
oh no what do you think was gonna happen
he tried to [ __ ] throw a disc 530
feet
he tried to [ __ ] throw a disc over
the green monster
let's watch this again just for [ __ ]
high hilarity sake
well his neck even whipped back a little
bit
look
oh i haven't seen this video i have a
feeling it's about to get a lot better
the guy comes out already with his hand
like this wants to give a high five
that was an ace and he's got a window a
windbreaker on and a straw hat
guy that's the disc golf of
outfits like pick a style
that just went in the bucket wow the
most the most new york guy ever hey get
out of here
this guy in greece hey get out of here
oh come on
tell us a story what happened just went
in the bucket get out of here
i banged my knee like super hard on that
throw i threw it
oh my god dude i banged my knee like
super hard on that
uh throw i throw it
right leg slipped out from under me left
knee actually banged hard on the ground
so much pain
right foot came out from under me left
knee banged hard on the ground
like it's like [ __ ] it's like an
after game so how do you feel oh well
okay so i don't know if you saw on the
uh if they play the highlight but um the
centrifugal force of it gets 530 feet
it's all in one now of course i'm proud
of it i banged my knee i don't know if
you saw but
um my right foot came out from under me
and i banged my knee pretty hard
but i hit the gap and we just saw
as i was laying on the ground i saw it
hook up and i'm pretty sure it like hit
the
cage and scooped right in why is he out
of breath
he threw one frisbee he looks fit
the [ __ ] is this guy i love
wow dude i mean if this guy isn't this
guy looks so much like my friend
when i was growing up in new jersey so
crazy
yeah that is crazy the baby d2 i might
have to retire this thing
unreal my knee pretty hard
wow dude professional disc golfer kevin
jones threw an incredible ace during a
fun practice round in advance
of the upcoming mvp open at maple hill
in
lychester massachusetts there i did
your job for you oh i guess
that was a comment but this was the
i don't know dude
this is from the guardian like
you ever you play frisbee you do that
you ever play frisbee you get like
one good throw every five throws you're
like all right [ __ ] it you do it 10
times you're like
it's spinning too hard to the right the
wind i don't i don't even feel wind
[ __ ] this and then you always get that
jackass that does it
like that just do it like this dude
we're
we're not like you're the ken griffey jr
of this
catching it in between their legs oh
it's nothing dude
guy's always fat who does it this guy
he's got a
a polo on he's got a polo on
and it's too small and the belly's
coming out and he's got
shorts on and [ __ ] flip-flops and
when he does it in between his legs
flip-flop always [ __ ] flops off and
you get pissed off
and his name's kent
disc golf
like it's the [ __ ] like it's like it's
the the a movie from trey parker matt
stone
can't believe i sang [ __ ] taylor eggs
and ham
[ __ ]
i guess that could be it oh we're at 109
okay
yeah i guess that's it
we had a good time and by we
i mean me um my
uh that's it
i gave my kid uh the moose toy again in
bed we'll see if he throws it out
stay tuned for that [ __ ] hot ticket
update um
but yeah that's it and i don't have much
more to say ah [ __ ] that guy through the
frisbee that was funny as [ __ ]
well guys that is the episode for
youtube
thank you for listening uh if you want
to listen to the
extended uncut version of this episode
you can on my patreon and you can do
that by going to patreon.comcrystalia
and if you sign up on the patreon you
can get a bunch of extra bonus contents
behind the scenes [ __ ] and then also uh
an
episode an extra episode every month so
thanks for listening either way
[Music]
okay ready here we go what's up baby
this is the